pas poser tout thierry mots on va
démarrer par benjamin castaldi cinq
minutes de questions vous répondez très
rapidement tiré à chaque fois vous devez
dire la vérité toute la vérité d'un cas
vérité benjamin attention trois deux un
top c'est parti c'est la question que
king ça fait des très longtemps il est
marié
oui il n'ya pas un si bel musicale
quelque chose et la question suivante
est ce qu'il ya une personne du paf qui
vous a émoustillé ou avec qui vous
auriez pu avoir le béguin comme on dit
le béguin
agathe agatha bah dis donc on aura un
gatinois il veut tous les cas bravo pas
les balles l'arrivée valbonne france je
suis flatté 1 gb lunettes moi aussi ma
pas calculer je n'ai jamais alors
thierry je n'ai jamais vu personne rire
à tes blagues sous valéry et moi et moi
elisabeth et toi tu te trouve drôle oui
c'est alors une très vite d'ailleurs une
alésienne du blog la différence entre un
pneu est un lapin
ils sont tous les deux en caoutchouc
sauf le lapin c'est une cata très
honnêtement encore tpm paix et si oui
est-ce que honnêtement est-ce que tu te
trouves que l'émission est de même
niveau de même niveau de qualité que
qu'auparavant alors très honnêtement je
ne la regarde pas tous les jours parce
que je travaille ma chronique
c'est là je la regarde de temps en temps
j'ai trouvé que lé mieux que l'année
dernière
à la fin de l'année dernière je trouve
qu'il ya plus de médias je trouve ça
très très bien merci je trouve que le
saut que maxime et hop voilà les
nouveaux chronos et s'ils pouvaient ne
pas être payé ça nous arrange tient à
bâle alors thierry au cas où tu
reviendrais tu sais qu'il ya des
fondamentaux qui change pas la donne et
de la danse est ce que tu as fait des
progrès dans ce domaine et si oui
montre-nous haut qu aucun progrès terme
aux guerres de dans aucun progrès dans
les airs aux patates intérêt ça je suis
un caillou une question tentation
thierry si on vous propose beaucoup
d'argent pour être chroniqueur chez
arthur ou chez yann barthez est ce que
vous acceptez pour beaucoup d'argent oui
cyril à bompas parce que la vraie
question c'est pour 1 et pour un célèbre
1 pour un montant normal ce que vous
accepteriez non non maxime question
rumeur il ya une rumeur insistante
il dit que vous avez été remercié de
télé 7 jours est ce vrai alors j'ai
quitté télé 7 jours il a quitté corps
dans les effectifs jusqu'à fin fin du
mois là on sait on est parti d'un commun
accord comme on dit tout simplement
parce que l'année dernière il ya eu ce
qu'on appelle un plan de départs
volontaires n'avait pas les gens qui
sont partis donc il était logique
ensuite que la direction
il y avait plusieurs personnes à la
direction dont moi face à des forêts
donc je suis parti est en accord jean
michel tu as bien compris tu nous avais
manqué mais toi quel est le chroniqueur
qui te manque que - le chroniqueur qui
manque le moins mathieu merci cronje de
valérie la question les yeux dans les
yeux
thierry les yeux dans les yeux est ce
qu'à un moment donné tu a regretté ton
départ de tpm paix n'ont à aucun moment
aucun en merda thierry tu pars en
vacances est obligé de partir avec l'un
des deux chroniqueurs soit mathieu
delormeau soit gilles verdès lequel
préfère partir en vacances
gilles gigantesque avec gilles et
françois ont tellement il y aura enfin
l'amour parce qu'on part en vacances on
fait l'amour
si si si si
si j'étais sur des questions clash
vous aviez dit en quittant touche pas à
mon poste que vous ne referiez plus de
télé pourquoi avoir menti non j'ai dit
que je ne quittais pas tt pmp pour un
projet télé j'avais pas de projet est
effectivement je n'avais aucun projet
télé je sais que sur internet il ya des
gens qui ont dit ah il revient sur ses
news est tout simplement la direction de
ces news fin août m'a appelé m'a dit
voilà il ya une matinale on change pas
mal de choses un bien est ce que ça vous
dit de venir près du coeur ça
correspondait un travail très
journalistique donc j'ai dit oui même si
au départ j'ai hésité parce que cette
levée tôt c'est compliqué quand on est
plutôt du square mais quand je suis
partie des pmp ce n'était pas pour faire
autre chose à la télé maki question bien
été thierry as tu déjà été seul ou deux
mois jamais provoqué non pas par le
condo tu me plais des cervidés de vérité
merci aimé de attention mathieu est ce
que la célébrité les facilités que
peuvent amener ce genre d'émission aussi
successfull que tpm peu de manque non
pas du tout benjamin question me paraît
que vous n'avez plus beaucoup de
contacts avec les chroniqueurs de
l'émission est ce vrai c'est vrai que
j'ai pas beaucoup de contacts j'ai pris
des nouvelles de valérie parce que elle
a été sur un lit de souffrance pendant
deux mois et ça m'a ennuyé j'ai changé
aussi avec jean luc lemoine
mais c'est vrai que j'ai pas eu beaucoup
de contacts pour sa part être une doit
aider j'en ai un
merci sincèrement thierry tu es passé
sur ces news on sait que ça fait partie
du groupe canal+ comme ces mythes
est-ce que c'est cyril hanouna qui t'a
pistonné pour entrer à ses news alors je
ne sais pas parce que je ne lui ai pas
demandé de pistonner je sais en revanche
que le patron de ces news a demandé
l'avis à cyril pour savoir si j'étais
quelqu'un de très sérieux le patron de
ses new skies a passé son avis il fait
ce qu'il veut il avait demandé votre
année c'est comme quand vous allez
passer quand vous passez d'un employeur
un autre souvent d ampleur que ça soit
bien je dis tir est un garçon formidable
il sera là tous les matins ils y perdent
période
bon je pense sont très contents de moi
c'est vous et merci tient tout est
question